o doido orgulho e aí a gente não tá tudo
bem com vocês beleza né agora pergunto
pra mim está tudo bem é muito pra mim
está tudo bem para a minha cara está
tudo bem não tá tudo bem vou explicar
porque agora névoa quebra sol que
aconteceu foi o seguinte 12 dias atrás
meu colega numa doca postou um vídeo no
youtube e fala de curso pela emaar
beleza o vídeo estourou ea gente quase
tem já tem um milhão de pizzas hunt
logicamente com o ponto que chama
atenção que aquelas pessoas que a fifa
comentando merda não sei o que lá e
passou que lá é normal tem uma loja que
ninguém é obrigado a entender nada
ninguém é obrigado a gostar de nada não
sou o cara quiser ver esse mal button 1º
normal beleza normal né
só que eu fui dar uma olhada nos
comentários do vídeo ea levo sempre
idéia é repetir vocês não têm idéia da
quantidade de comentários
preconceituosos eu vi no comentário do
tipo a cara por isso que o nordeste a
escolha do brasil
olha o tipo de vídeo com o pessoal do
nordeste joga no youtube corra nordeste
a história do brasil é tu sabe o que é o
nordeste cara de cavalo tu sabes 50%
alimento fica na tua mesmo não sabe aqui
ingraçado e vejam bem essas respostas
aos comentários de que eu vi no rio
bonito
não são as pessoas do sul as pessoas
estão é especificamente a pessoa que no
momento está no jornalismo também todos
os estados do nordeste que eu andei todo
mundo me recebeu super bem graças ao
mesmo tempo não é o tipo de gente
tivesse um cliente no haiti um
comentário assim ela no nordeste para
colocar os gays nas vacas eles olhar com
o mato sempre achar que o mapa verde
o nordeste é um lixo tá beleza mas e
oculto
de hoje a us mas você não aguenta uma
brincadeira uma amp a dinha no meu filho
piada é bem diferente pra conseguir
ficar parado na pizzaria do mato velho e
já tava tribuna e até chegar à sala mas
eu quero falar que o nordeste é lixo aí
perdeu a graça e até de viver no mesmo
país que uma pessoa dessa aí houve o
comentário assim ah moleque no nordeste
no meio do mato e agravando ea zon
passam muita de barril
o animal se tu acha que aqui no piauí
o cara ontem avançou bom passando tocha
que seu corpo já bom time um pouco no
meio da rua à risca e jack chan de lesão
no braço maru tem olha que beleza é mais
o animal não deve ser bem diferente
disso
desde o início eu vou eu vou discutir
conseguir parar por aqui vai ver o que
importa é que a falta de chuva não faz
pouco tempo disse que não choquem disse
aqui no shopping shopping civil e até
tempestade de areia ou brincando você
sabe que coisa que você sabe que foi
esse aqui você que foi ampliado que eu
tirei ele mesmo sabe o que é isso aí
você é você fazer piada o tudo de muito
está acontecendo com você que é isso
nordeste no país é esse o destino para
não deixar um povo alegre é um pouco da
energia e hoje você é o tipo de pessoa
preconceituosa 10 quando vou deixar aqui
um conselho pra você e como consegue
ouvir da boca do meu primo rodolfo manhã
em brasília que é uma coisa que eu nunca
vou esquecer na minha vida a atenção
para a frase não há nenhum ser humano
que não precisa de outro não há ninguém
que não precisa de outro só que
significa essa frase se você com
preconceito ou nordestino um dia você
vai precisar de uma coisa que só na
china open que você com preconceito ozu
com ele com o índio homossexual um dia
você vai precisar de uma coisa que só
essas pessoas têm aí que você vai para o
tipo de pessoa que eu souber porque não
sei você mas o meu
o meu povo da minha terra é o melhor o
melhor lugar para se viver
aqui é um lugar se você chegar com fome
cansado o cara vai abrir a porta pra
você entrar vai dar comida ea do evento
não validar cama confortável segundo eu
espero do fundo do meu coração que todos
vocês estão assistindo agora seja assim
também não quis ofender ninguém as
respostas aqui nesse vídeo foi
direcionado diretamente às pessoas que
comentaram não tô falando ninguém nenhum
estado e é isso aí é isso aí me desculpo
por incomodar eu só quero deixar um
recado pra vocês o nordeste é [ __ ] viu
falou